(audience applauds and cheers)
- I'm gonna, I'm gonna
like talk about a lot.
- I never know how to
sit on these couches.
- Me neither. I know, I know.
- Do I do this? This?
- I always have to sit on the end.
- Okay? So sit on the end.
- [Kelly] I'm all torso and no legs.
- Okay. Yeah. There we go.
- Yeah. So I mentioned
your Grammy nomination.
So congratulations.
You were just nominated again.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you.
- That's so cool.
So you shot the music video,
"I'm Good on a Boat".
Was that fun?
Do you like being on a boat?
I get sick on a boat.
- Oh man.
It was like, it looked like very grand.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- The boat looked really
grand on the music video.
It looked, you know, but it was old boat
and the hydraulics or,
I don't know what the
proper terminology is.
- So you were rocking.
- So it was like so bumpy and
we were just like holding on.
I have literally pictures
of everybody in my-
oh, there I go. Yeah.
- This is not what I look
like on a boat (laughs)
(audience cheers)
- So, but then...
- I'm yacking off the side. (laughs)
- Oh gosh.
- Yeah.
Everybody was like throwing
up and like, it was crazy.
- Oh really?
- Oh yeah.
I was like, I was like
so close to throwing up
but I like was like holding myself.
I was like, if I,
because you know when
you shoot a music video,
you're shooting the whole day.
- Yeah, yeah.
You know how it goes.
- So I was like, if I throw
up now I am going to be,
wait, there's people on the wall?
- Yeah.
(audience laughs)
So we have people from all over.
Yeah.
(audience cheers)
So we, during Covid, the
whole audience was actually
screens like this and they
could tune in from all over
and we thought it was kind of cool.
- That's so cool!
- So we kept some of it.
Yeah. Yeah.
They're not vomiting, which is
even better right now. Yeah.
- You can tell 'em I have
A.D.D cuz I'm just like whoa~
- I am 100% the same way.
So I told, I went with you. Squirrel.
Well your parents, and
especially your mama,
have really inspired and
supported you, right?
That's awesome.
- Yeah.
- Yeah? Has that been...
Have you always been into it?
Cuz I remember whenever I told my mom...
- No, no, no, no.
They have not always been into it.
- Yeah.
- Especially my dad.
(Kelly laughs)
Well, because, you know
- Was he the one that
responsible, like backup plan?
- Well, he...
Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, my dad would
always tell me like
cuz it was such, you know,
it's such a struggle in this industry.
- Yeah.
- So he'd always be like,
"Don't worry about it."
Like, "You always got a roof on.
You got a roof here, you
could always come back to me.
You gotta - I gotta some food. I got-."
(audience says aww)
He's like, you know, he'll
remind me cuz sometimes
I get stressed and he's like, he's like-
Don't cry.
- Aww.
(audience says aww)
That's nice though, to
have that kind of support.
Not every artist has that.
- Now he's going to make me cry.
Dad!
- Look, I'm fully prepared just in case.
Here you go.
- Okay. No, no.
- Yeah. I cry all the time on the show.
- Yes.
- Well I love that though.
The support I really wanted to bring up.
- I think in the beginning
he was really, he was really nervous
because, you know, he's an immigrant.
Like, he doesn't, he
doesn't know this country.
He didn't know the music business.
And the music business is all
drug sex and rock and roll.
Which it is.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Yeah.
- So, but it's like, but they raised me.
I think they, they raised me pretty well.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But I think they were mostly scared
cuz you don't know what to expect
in this industry, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- So.
- And even when you're
in it, it's still hard.
Like even when you've had
massive, massive successes,
it's still-
- Oh it's, you know,
- Yeah.
- like, it's like you could
have success and then people-
- It's still this!
- It's up, it's ebbs and flows.
You know what I mean?
- Like every life, every job, yeah.
- Yeah. Like, yeah.
- And that's hard when you
don't have a support system.
And I know that I've had
this my whole career as well
but I know that you've
had haters online and you-
- Oh my God, all the time.
- I know.
I love that you call 'em out though.
I love that.
(audience applauds)
- Oh, I call them out.
- I used to call 'em out and be like
you're voted off the island.
Like I would, I would call it that.
And then I just got exhausted
cuz there were so many (laughs).
- The best thing is not
to read the comments
and to ignore them.
- [Kelly] I don't.
- because like, you're feeding-
you'll never make anybody happy.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like you'll say something
positive and there's always
one person that's gonna
find something that's like,
"I can't believe you just said that!"
And it's like, you
never, you'll never win.
So sometimes it's good to leave it alone.
But the New Yorker in me
and like, you know, the
- The female in you
- Female in me.
- [Kelly] is like, "I'm sorry, what?"
- [Bebe] You know what I mean?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah. There I
- [Kelly] It's hard.
- You know, I was on
TikTok like the other day
and I, listen, I'm a
woman, I have my struggles.
I like, I've had definitely
struggled a lot with food.
- Yeah, me too. I love it.
That's the problem.
- I know the bitch has to eat.
You know what I mean?
(audience cheers and applauds)
- I think it's good.
- It's really good. But also-
- And I'm social about it.
I love going out.
- So Yeah.
I use people also as like, my crutches.
It's terrible.
Like, oh we have to, we
have to get the extra tacos!
- We're celebrating.
It's Tuesday, let's do it.
- Yeah, exactly.
But also like there, I think we're in 2023
and I think people need to
like chill out a little bit.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
I saw like the whole Ariana Grande thing.
It's like, I don't think
it's anybody's place
to talk about anybody's image.
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- Like she's beautiful.
(audience cheers)
- Absolutely. And pipes for dang!
- One of the best points!
- That's the thing that
drives me nuts is like,
just shut up.
And first of all, close your eyes.
Like the whole reason why she's there.
Like that's, I don't know
what's going on with her
- You don't know what
anyone one is going through.
- You don't know their background,
you don't know their health.
You don't know anything like that.
Either way.
Skinny, thick, whatever it is.
(audience claps)
But also, like,
that's not your job isn't that.
Your job is an artist.
You're writing music.
You're singing music.
- But I take it though cuz
we're in the public eye
so no matter what, it
comes with the territory.
- I'm from a small town,
so it's been like this my whole life.
(Bebe laughs)
Like everybody has always
had something to say.
- Oh girl. Yeah. I'm sure. I'm sure.
- Which I think is helpful.
It prepares you.
- Yes and no.
- Yeah.
- But I think, I forgot
what I wanted to say now,
- Because we're both A.D.H.D.
This should go well.
- Yeah. Literally.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience cheers)
- So your new album drops
today and it's called Bebe.
And I wanna ask you about that
because I've actually never
named an album my name
because I always feel
like it's hard because
I feel like I'm like
multiple artists in here.
So why did you do it?
Why'd you name it Bebe?
- I think for me it was more of like my,
just my whole journey.
And I feel like, you know,
I was telling somebody the other day
that when I did the Jonas Brothers tour,
I remember I was
(audience cheers)
- I love them.
Yeah. They're great.
- Yeah. They're amazing.
They, yeah, I was performing
and I opened up for them.
And when I would, when I would
perform everybody like, wait
that's your, that's her?
That's her, that's her song?
- Oh.
- And I'm just like, it's, yeah.
It's crazy cuz I'll, I feel
like more people know my songs
and actually know what
I look like or who I am.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Or what my background
is or where I come from.
Or they don't even know.
- [Kelly] Which is kind of cool.
- Which is kind of cool.
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- Yeah. They think I'm
like English or something.
It's, it's just...
(Kelly laughs)
I'm from New York,
you know what I mean?
(Kelly laughs)
Like I'm a New York girl
(audience applauds)
but I just feel like for
me it was mostly like
I didn't wanna like,
I just wanted to name something
where people could actually learn.
Like, like I wanted people
to know more about who I am.
- Yeah. That's understandable.
- Yeah. So I think it's time
for people to know who Bebe Rexha is.
- Yeah.
(audience cheers and applauds)
It's it's amazing though
because you've been killing it
for so many years.
- So it's like wild.
- I know, that's what I'm saying.
It's amazing.
And I think that is kind of
exciting as an artist though
when you go to a show
like, and you forget.
Like you go there and you're like,
oh my God, I forgot about this song.
I forgot about this song.
- [Bebe] Yeah
- I love that reminder.
Like when you see someone live.
Anyway.
So you have worked with
a lot of great artists
and you've worked with a lot
of great artists on the album,
which I love both.
- Yeah.
- You've worked with
Snoop, that Satellite.
- Yeah.
- Which is so good.
- Thank you.
It's one of my favorites.
(audience applauds)
- I love Satellite.
I love this man too.
Like, I've worked with him.
- I wanna tell the story
of like how I hit him up
and like how the song came about.
- That's what I was gonna ask you.
Like how did, how did you call him?
- I, I, okay.
So like, usually a lot of
times you go through management
or you go through like
the label or whatever,
but I am like, I've always been a hustler
and I feel like you have
to always kind of hustle
to like make things
happen yourself sometimes.
- Yeah.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Yeah.
- So I went on this, I went on Instagram
and I was like let me
just send out a message.
- Oh my God. You did not.
I love this.
- Yeah.
- I love that.
- And I said, "Hey, I have a song.
I would love to send it to you.
If you like it,
I would love for you to
like rap on it or what.
Do your thing.
If not, totally fine.
I won't, I won't take it-
You know, I want you to really like it."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then he called me the next morning
at 7:00 AM with a blunt in his mouth.
- Sure.
(audience laughs)
- And he like smoked
and he like blew the smoke to the phone.
And he's like, "Check your email."
And I was like, woo!
(Kelly claps)
(audience cheers)
- I love that.
It's so good.
- It's one of my favorite songs.
- I got like chills.
This, I was like, this
is such a great song.
- Yeah. I love-
It's called Satellite with Snoop.
It's one of my favorite
songs on the album.
- Higher than a Satellite.
Come on.
- Yeah.
- I was like-
- Well we were really inspired,
I was really inspired by
Elton John, Rocket Man.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(audience cheers)
- I didn't know what that song was about.
- I don't think I did
when I was younger either.
Most songs I was singing.
- Yeah, exactly.
- They are like highly
inappropriate, but you don't know.
- Yeah, right?
(Kelly laughs)
Remember this song,
♪ You gonna go on the counter? ♪
- [Kelly] I had no idea.
- I was singing that.
Like, I remember singing that so loud
and loving that song and not
knowing what it was about.
- I'm older than you
and I was singing Red
Light Special by TLC.
(Bebe groans)
Oh that's so inappropriate
(audience laughs)
for like a 12 year old.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah. But I had no idea
what I was singing about.
I just loved the song.
Yeah. I was like,
♪ Give me the red light special. ♪
And I'm like, what?
I was like, why it's so gross.
- Oh my God.
- Like for 12 year old.
Anyway, you don't know.
But also you're singing with
one of my other favorites.
Dolly. Seasons.
- Dolly Parton.
Yeah.
(audience cheers)
- There is a part of the
song where I swear to you,
I was like, your vibratos
almost sound similar.
- Yeah.
- There's a part where you're just like,
wait, which one is which at one point.
And the song, when I was listening.
How did that come about?
- I tried like, hitting
up her manager a lot.
- Because she doesn't,
y'all she still sends faxes.
I'm not kidding.
- Oh yeah.
She- I remember, I, I
- It's hard.
You gotta send a bird for that one.
(audience laughs)
It's kinda, like a pigeon.
- So they were like, "Hey, okay sure.
Send us a song, but we need it on a CD."
And I was like, I don't have a,
I don't know how to make like,
I don't remember.
(Kelly laughs)
I don't know how to like make a-
- I know, I'm telling you.
That's so funny because I've
done something with her.
- But she's so sweet.
I had another song prior to this one.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it was talking about,
it was a song about heaven
and hell and stuff like that.
And she was like, I can't.
She wrote me a handwritten letter.
- Totally her.
- And telling me why she
doesn't wanna sing about hell.
Cuz she, you know heaven and
hell like, she doesn't wanna
like she doesn't, you know, wanna say
- She didn't wanna invest in
that kind of conversation.
- Yeah.
She didn't wanna add that,
she didn't wanna go into that energy.
So then I sent her Seasons.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And she loved it.
And then a week later
she sent me her verse.
- Well, Seasons sounds like
something she would've recorded.
That's why it's so perfect
how that worked out.
Way to go for her being honest and polite.
Like sending you something-
- She is the nicest.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- She's the nicest, one of the
nicest people I've ever met.
And she's the funniest.
- [Kelly] So funny.
- She said she would adopt me.
So wherever the camera is right now.
Dolly.
(Kelly laughs)
You said you were gonna adopt me and
- You don't look far off.
It's like beautiful bombshell.
- I mean. I, I, I wish, I mean, sorry mom.
- [Kelly] Yeah. (laughs)
- But.
- She does not wish that. (laughs)
- No, but. It was, she's such an icon.
Like she's not like
not only just an artist
but she is a songwriter.
She had, she wrote,
I Will Always Love You by Whitney.
- [Kelly] Yeah yeah.
So many more songs.
- [Kelly] Jolene, all of songs.
- So we shot a music video together
which is coming out today as well.
(audience cheers)
- (indistinct) She shows up ready.
- Oh!
- She shows up ready!
- Girl!
She put me to shame.
Let me tell you.
I thought I looked good.
I was like, okay, I feel good.
I have my corset on, my heels.
She showed up in six inch heels.
- [Kelly] Yep.
- Six inch heels.
- Just!
- A corset.
Her (beep) were like this high,
(Kelly laughs)
like, and I was like,
and she was ready to go.
She's like, whatever you need, let's go.
Let's get this done.
- She's so professional.
- Yes. (indistinct)
- I didn't ask her. I
wanted to ask her something
and I forgot. I chickened out.
- [Kelly] What did you wanna ask her?
- I wanted to see if she had tattoos.
- You know, here's the thing, people.
It's been a thing cuz she's
always got her arms covered.
People have always said she has tattoos.
I've never seen this either.
- That's my goal.
I'm gonna find out.
(few chuckles in the audience)
- I don't know if I wanna know.
- [Bebe] Okay.
(audience laughs)
- I kind of, I think I don't wanna know.
And I wanna pretend that she's
got full sleeves. (laughs)
(audience laughs)
Like I wanna pretend that
Dolly Parton has full sleeves
and it's just like,
just has a Harley
and it's just like on weekends
just roaming the planet.
- [Bebe] I mean, I.
- Yeah.
Yeah. That's what I need
to know in my brain.
Anyway. I love her.
I love Seasons though.
It's a damn great song.
- Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- I cannot wait to sing
it one day. (laughs)
I love it.
All right everybody.
Bebe's gonna perform
later so stick around.
You do not wanna miss it.
(audience cheers)
It's incredible.
The new album is called Bebe.
And you can find it
wherever you get your music.